this man to my right who was here a few
years ago promoting the kingdom that was
right here on audience what a great show
that was we also enjoy his work in the
purge film series and now you can check
him out in fight world as he is the host
of a five-part installment travel
document a documentary series that
streaming right now on Netflix good to
see you Frank thank you Matt Grillo how
are you I'm good yeah yeah I'm still
here now what you just said that I was
we went to break you think cubby was
done with the UFC you know I think if
it's a very delicate situation you know
he said he's just he's a hero where he
comes from yeah and and a lot of people
support him and a lot of people think
he's a hero for beating the crap out of
Conor McGregor oh he just didn't beat
him up I mean he humiliated him you know
that that jaw crank was shouldn't happen
to a professional fighter right yeah and
listen everyone knew the level of talent
of khabib and he pretty proved it if he
would have stayed in the cage man you
know just kind of yeah you know but and
you definitely know this having been
exposed to the world through Kingdom
yeah and learning about mixed martial
arts and being immersed in that world as
yeah you were as an actor it's difficult
to say get in the mindset yet to get in
the Octagon yeah get in the mindset to
do to another human being or be prepared
to have that done to you yeah and then
when the bell goes off just shake hands
and you know and come back to society
and having traveled around so much
around the world and to understand how
serious
someone like abebe takes his religion
mm-hmm his family you know where he's
from and and the way McGregor kind of
you know you you you poke the bear
enough and you know it's a visceral
emotional moment and you lose it it's
like I was saying backstage it's like a
hockey fight I mean what's the
difference
you know that's equally as illegal to
have a melee on ice but I think as you
pointed out though the fact that he
hopped the fence yeah he's into the view
of these into the general Houston he was
like a silverback the way he left off of
the apron into this like when he's still
in the mindset of being in the octagon
to that killer
it's not as if he's like okay I'm now
I'm Alka beam the person against the
fence right so he's enraged yeah and so
you know I I joked before like can we
just get past all this stuff like the
stuff being bought the the Athletic
Commission needing to figure out what's
going on the UFC needing you figure out
the liability and all of that stuff
right and as you said if he had only
stayed in in the cage then he would not
have all of these legal issues or visa
issues right hanging over him right it's
a problem it's gonna be a big problem I
don't know that you'll ever see them
fight again I don't know that we should
I mean he really made a point of Conor
McGregor saying I'm just too good um
he's a far superior fighter far superior
well based again on being part of the
world as you is you were four Kingdom
what what did you learn of what somebody
goes through to get in that mindset to
be in that octagon for people like even
me who I train every day among the gym
every day a boxer I do all kinds of
great stuff I don't know when I when I
would travel around the night you know
I'm with guys in Thailand bull cow who's
the greatest Muay Thai fighter that's
that's what fascinated me that's why I
wanted to do this shows like I try to
understand what could put a person man
or woman into this frame of mind where
you are willing to risk everything you
talk about fight world you're just
talking about fighters like you know
what makes them do this it's not money
because most of them don't make a lot of
money so it's something it's it goes
against almost human nature to want to
do that you know it's it's remark so
what do you think did you put your
finger on I think I think these people
are born with with just different DNA
than most people you know it really
hurts to fight not just to get in there
leading up to that the amount of
training the amount of knowledge that
you need to have it's it's remarkable
and by the way it's not unlike when I
when you see warriors battle Navy SEALs
or Special Ops guys you know the
training
it takes the risk that they're willing
to to put their lives in it right it's
it's a very different human being and
how can you put that in the New York
Yankees when it counts against the
glossary Yankee I can't take it anymore
I the Giants the Yankees tired of it
Giants I don't know if you're able to
catch any of the game last night or a
little bitter or done I know you're done
huh I'm done I'm done
I may be numb now I don't know a Dallas
Cowboy fans oh my god frank grillo
they'll not let you back home he'll let
you back home you know what Rich Eisen
this is my home Los Angeles I mean I'm a
California okay so now you're gonna be a
LeBron guy is what you're saying I am a
LeBron I've always been a LeBron guy man
I think one of the greatest athletes of
all time I agreed yeah I agree well do
not be a LeBron guy Chris I like
watching LeBron play but he makes it
hard sometimes oh he's such a specimen
yes anything about sports which I know
maybe you do I don't know watch him do
not doubting that first media day and
the first practice and he walked past
Wow
I write a couple of years since I wasn't
you know in his presence yeah was in the
same room not on watching him play like
actually on the same ground level as
used to him he is bigger than I Ramona I
stop I couldn't even imagine shoulders
four days yes I could not imagine if he
wanted to play tight end but what would
happen and he could do anything he could
be President
well we'll find out one day won't we in
this day and age you never know Frank
Grillo here on the Rich Eisen show so
fight world how did this come about I
mean cuz you're you're a family man
you're an actor what made you want to
travel the world and start learning
about warriors and fighting yeah now a
couple of martial arts a couple things I
love Anthony Bourdain it's all I used to
watch was Anthony Bourdain Shore
arrested so that was kind of the genesis
the idea and throughout my career I've
traveled around the world and wherever I
went there was a gym and I'd go to the
gym and it wasn't the people outside of
the gym it
the guys I learned to fight with
wherever I was that kind of taught me
the culture of the place for two weeks
for a week whatever it wasn't it's like
there's a through line here there's a
Brotherhood here and maybe we could do
what Bourdain does only instead of
embedding myself from food culture I
didn't bet myself from flight culture
and Netflix love the idea I mean the
next thing you know I was on an airplane
next thing you know you're on an
airplane just like that okay and there's
a start bench cut that we like to do
here on the Rich Eisen show which is a
game where I give you three choices okay
you have to start one you have to bench
one and cut one okay
okay so that's the way we go here okay
so first one up for frank grillo here
for your series white world you travel
the world again to learn about the
different fighting styles which country
did you enjoy most Israel Thailand or
Myanmar you have to start one
you have to bench one is not one start
is real okay
I'd bench Thailand I'd cut me and more
yeah is it has to do with just uh you
know the whole tight-fisted missus
its catch any trouble this is tough but
it's politically what was going on when
I was there it was it was upsetting
off-putting and and and subsequently
what I learned about Israel was so
surprisingly uplifting and Thailand
falls somewhere in the middle no kidding
yeah which which food did you like the
most the food yeah when you were there
in Israel
you know just anywhere Oh Israel's food
was amazing the hummus and all the veg
everything was very fresh
Thailand's food was was also my favorite
I loved it I've been to tell me many
times okay um Nemo maybe it's the
British you know they colonized the
place it was Burma I don't know how many
yelp reviews there are of the places in
Myanmar and how many yelps there are was
the last time you ate fast food uh like
literally when was the last time you ate
fast
I don't remember look come on now I
don't eat I don't eat fast wait Pizza
what about I mean if my kids are having
pizza or maybe I'll take a bite but
mostly I won't
and I need to get that sort of attitude
really
Pizza mate I love it but it you know it
makes me ill makes you ill yeah for that
kind of food you're from New York
I haven't eaten like that this is all
New York are you done from New York can
you tell from New York City
yeah graduate of NYU right yeah okay
right you you you you worked on Wall
Street right now I'm an actor I worked
on while I was 20 years old I was you're
like bud Fox here we go start bench cut
frank grillo your father of three kids
what's the best fighting style for kids
to learn jujitsu take a tight Taekwondo
or cut a you have to start venture cut
one I would have to start jujitsu it's
my thing I would bench Taekwondo and I
would cut karate chop you chopped karate
I would chop Wyatt Wyatt why's that you
know it's it's very uh it's laden with
Coty's and it's it's for me it's just
it's just it's too much repetitive stuff
before the fun things happen and it's
medicine and it's it's stupid for me to
say that but okay and I love jiu-jitsu
so jiu-jitsu is like okay so scratch
frank grillo off of season two of Cobra
Kai all right and then the last one
because again you were here the last
time you were here and I have a
beautiful black-and-white photograph of
me and khakis yeah and a button-down
shirt with my it with my dog getting on
the you brought it out of last time
wasn't the dog the dog is beautiful rest
rest his soul yeah but look at your arms
it's not with you why are your pants wet
exactly right why are you wearing pants
that I think is is outdone only by the
framed crossword puzzle in your ear
with your name yes your name I mean it's
a bit much
I was 32 across you were a clue I know
you framed it so my parents they were
they were clever but take it out of the
bathroom at least put it in the game
these got it's gotta be somewhere all
right so the last one best place to run
with your dog the beach the park or
mountains frank grillo i i got it i got
it was great I gotta say that the the
park would be my you start start here
and start there
I would absolutely cut the beach you
should cut the beach or at least wear
shorts
[Laughter]
good to see you Frank thanks no thanks
for coming on congrats on fight world
come back any time you want thank you
your your local here since now a Los
Angeles guide pizza I've cut be fun I've
cut New York my god have you got the
Giants I cut the Yankees go nice to be
honest the Yankees cut you the Yankees
benched you they've been Giants cotton
shines kill me frank grillo check out
fight world on Netflix right now the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience